MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a questions and
answer show.
So, if any of you out there
would like to ask questions--
IDO GREEN: GDL Israel.
GDL-IL.
Today we're going to focus
on the Google Cloud
Endpoint and HTML5.
And before we jump into the
few slides I've prepared,
let's speak real briefly on
the news from yesterday.
Google + have a new sign-in.
And, I guess, if you are a
front-end developer and you
want to check out how to
leverage it and use it in your
websites, web apps, and even
on mobile apps on Android,
just search on
Googledevelopers.com/live.
There are a few other episodes
that are dedicated for it, and
it will give you a great summary
of how you could tap
into it, and use it more
effectively and easier.
Let me share my screen
with you.
Let's jump real quick here.
And even before that, let's have
this nice Hangout shared
with others.
And we're done.
OK, so without further
ado, let me share
my screen with you.
And we could tap into some of
the slides that I've created.
So, this is basically a talk
that I gave during the last
DevCon Tel Aviv, which was
a great conference.
If you are a web developer,
front-end developer located in
Israel, I highly recommend you
to check out DevCon it's a
really, really great
conference.
One nice tweak that you have in
this slide is-- by the way,
you could watch the slides
later on here,
ido-green.appspot.com and it's
the first slide basically.
All those fields are editable.
So, this is basically where you
could see those slides,
and if you want, you basically
just do whatever you like with
those tiny fields.
So, to the ones that don't
know me, I'm acting as
Developer Advocate here at
Google focusing Chrome HTML5,
Google Cloud.
I'm mainly active these
days on G+.
And you could search Ido
Green or on Twitter.
Or on my blog just feel free.
We do have this episode of
GDL-IL, GDL Israel, every
Wednesday at 2:00 PM Israel time
for 25, 30 minutes, so
just feel free to join us.
And if you have questions,
we'll love to try and
help you with them.
By the way, if you're joining
the Hangout, please try to
start with mute, and only if you
have question just ping me
on the chat and I will be happy
to try and answer them.
So, let's try and jump into what
we're going to do today.
We are going speak, basically,
about Mobile App Engine
Backends, which we called
Google Cloud Endpoints.
And see how you, as a developer,
can leverage them,
use them, and be more effective
when you are writing
your code, maintaining it, and
later on consuming it from
other platforms like Android,
iOS, and, of course, the web.
Then we're going to define
real quick what is
a modern web app.
What are the main characteristic
that we want
see in a web app.
And, then, that real briefly
we'll speak about some of the
tools and the APIs that I find
very exciting these days.
Last, but not least, I'll try to
open Chrome DevTools, which
I'm really passionate about.
And give you some tips to make
you more productive when
you're working with it.
This is thanks to our
sponsors, but we
don't need it today.
Google Cloud Endpoint
is basically based
on Google App Engine.
Now, what is Google
App Engine?
Very similar to Chrome, which
is based on three S's--
security, speed,
and simplicity.
On Google App Engine, we have
three other things.
It's easy to build and develop
your specific app on it.
It's easy to scale it because
you don't have
to worry about it.
And it's easy to maintain it.
Its platform is a service,
and you are doing
what you're best at.
Meaning, you're developing
your unique app.
And let Google App Engine scale,
and maintain, and use
all the benefits that we're
giving you as a platform.
As you can see from this slide,
even in Google metrics,
App Engine is pretty
big these days.
It's passed 7.5 billion
daily hits.
And you can see here on the
timeline that it's growing
pretty fast, up and
to the right.
Some core features that
we have today.
Of course, you could read all of
them from the slide, but I
would just focus on a few things
that are roughly new.
It's not brand new,
but it's something
in the past 12 months.
And if you haven't been
following, probably, you
missed it or haven't seen it.
I will focus first on
what start-ups are
keeping asking me.
It's great that we have the
largest No SQL database in the
world, but if I'm working with
My SQL, do I have any option
to work with it on top
of Google App Engine?
And the answer is yes.
We do have Cloud SQL, which
basically giving you
My SQL in the Cloud.
And, of course, you could check
the water with data
storage, which basically
giving you a
very nice No SQL option.
We also have Memcache.
That's another hot topic.
And in terms of your compute,
we have lots of different
types of features and abilities
to give you the
ability to run jobs that are
faster than 30 seconds or
immediate request that you will
do to any rest API or
your web app.
We have large set off APIs.
And we'll see later on how you
could tap into them, play with
them through the API Explorer,
and get the feel to them even
before you are writing
one line of code.
And, of course, huge
amount of services.
Some of them are your own
proprietary service that you
could run from, or on
top of, App Engine.
And some are just APIs and
services that Google is
offering you.
As you can see, a month in the
life of an App Engine.
Lots of big names there--
Gigya, Khan Academy, Best Buy.
All of them are running on true
production mode in App Engine.
And I highly encourage you to
check out the blog post that
Khan Academy did that summarizes
what they had in
terms of experience of a large
spike in traffic after a "60
Minutes" interview that
they did Sal Khan.
A type of storage, as we said,
a fully-managed no SQL
solution that basically holding
the largest no SQL
database in the world--
two trillion operations
per month.
So, even if you have a really
hot app that is flourishing on
the Play marketplace, you
are in good hands.
You don't need to worry about
sharding, and scaling, and
some reverse proxying, and SQIDs
and vernish, and all of
the good stuff that if you ever
been in another platform
you need to master it.
Here, all the work is done for
you with the best practices.
Yeah, basically we
know what to do.
How to split and make sure that
you are up and running.
And, yeah, it's spread between
few data centers.
A very nice, compelling example
is Get Around, which
after they won, their
[INAUDIBLE].
You can see the graph there.
Pretty huge and they were up
and running all the time.
The main motivation, here, is
that in these days, basically,
what you want to do is create
your secret sauce, and have a
nice rest API that later on that
you could consume from
multiple platforms.
Of course, the web is the
biggest out there, but let's
no deceive ourselves,
we do have a very
big, flourishing ecosystem.
And Android is a huge
these days.
And then you have to scale it.
Especially if you are on Android
and your app is in the
top 10 list somewhere, you do
want to be in safe water.
When we come in to check what
we want to do in terms of
design this encapsulates
basically what you see again
and again in start-up lines.
Basically, you want some shared
stake in the back-end,
some 1 source of true that you
hold all your data in state
about your user.
Maybe, in the future, you'll
want to use some other
services like search,
mail, et cetera.
And then on top of them, you'll
want the application
logic that is creating your
secret sauce and giving your
specific service.
And, of course, these days you
need to create some kind of
API that all your
different client
could consume and leverage.
And then you start
to implement it.
And like we know in life, it
starting simple and quite
quickly you get into more
and more features.
You need to share the database
because you have a huge amount
of data in it.
You want authentication,
authorization, login,
compression, performance, and
lots of goodness to build into
the API that you started and
thought it would be just,
let's say, crude application
with very different or very
simple set of APIs endpoints.
Usually quite quickly you're
ending up with quite a lot of
things to manage.
And, then, let's not forget, you
do need to write some sort
of API wrapper per platform.
So, here, in our case, you need
to do it once in Java,
then in Objective C, and of
course in JavaScript so you
can consume it from the web.
And then after launch, and
hopefully a successful one,
you need to start being in the
head of the administrator or
slash ops that know how to
maintain the middle-ware, know
how to add features on time,
and make sure that all the
engines will work while
the plane is flying.
And then in Google Cloud
Endpoints, basically, we
saving you, again,
lot of leg works.
So, the secret sauce here, or
the proof is in the pudding,
is actually being built and
used inside Google and--
luckily for us and I'm
really glad to see
it again and again--
being open to the world to
other developers in other
companies to leverage and
enjoy it and use it.
You can see similar
examples like
Angular.js and other projects.
And now in this one, basically
we're giving you the goodness
of App Engine, but then with
the dedicated option to
leverage the benefits of what
we already baked in Google
Cloud Endpoints.
So basically, you have the
shared state that you want.
You have the data store.
You're focusing on your
application logic.
And from the minute you're
starting to run with it, you
have already there is the case
that we have to Google APIs
that you could leverage and
use in your own APIs.
Let's see how does it look
more thoroughly.
When we are speaking about how
it's related, we have the
ability to discover, and
actually have the glue between
the front-end and
the back-end.
In this example, you could see
the Google API Explorer giving
you the ability to go to any
service basically that we have
on Google-- and I'll try to make
it a bit bigger-- and you
could see a huge amount
of services.
In each service, I could play
with it and see what are the
main endpoints that I could
leverage and use.
Let's go just quickly for
the simplicity with
the example of G+.
You could see immediately
what I could do in
each and every endpoint.
And let's say that I'm going
to the activity.
I need to have some ID.
But, then, if I'm executing,
immediately you're getting a
response with this specific
get command.
And, of course, I don't have
here a certain value so I'm
not getting the right
information.
But I can see exactly what's
happening here.
And it's really easy to hold and
have the glue between the
front-end and the back-end
developer when we speaking
about a new ability
to discover.
Basically everything will be
backed in adjacent format,
which is very easy to run tests
against and to check
what we need to get from
that back-end.
And, of course, very,
very easy to
consume it from the web.
You are, basically, loading
Google API Client in
JavaScript.
And then, in this example, for
instance, you're loading the
URL shortener, and you
can work with it.
And, of course, we are
supporting I would say quite a
lot of main languages
and technologies.
So every developer could choose
the ones that they are
most productive with.
The great things about it is
basically you could create
your own API and get the same
service or level of
discoverability, and later
on maintainability.
In this example, and I highly
encourage you to check other
Google Developer Live episodes
that are dedicated to Google
Cloud Endpoints, which giving
you a great example of live
coding in the Python App
Engine environment.
And basically they gave the
great example of the
tic-tac-toe game.
But you could take it and
just think about your
own specific scenario.
In this case, you're writing
your back-end code, you
decorate the API method
very easily
both in Java and Python.
Then, generating the client
libraries for you.
And you're writing your client
app based on the platform that
you want to target--
Android, the web,
iOS, et cetera.
Here is the URL that you
could play with.
And, basically, I could show
you real quick how
does it look like.
So, as you could see, it's
a very simple, nice game.
Hopefully, I'll win.
Yeah.
And you could do view source
later and just see exactly
what's going on there.
And of course, who's
is next playing?
And this is our API.
And here if you want to run it
on mobile, of course it will
run on the major platforms
out there.
And here are two links to the
tic-tac-toe game and Birra
demo app that I did
in the last iO.
And you could see our Birra
rating app and actually all
the good things that you could
check with it live.
In terms of search for good
beers, insert a new beer, get
a list of beers, et cetera.
Let's, just for fun, see
what's happening here.
And right now it's down, but
hopefully it will be up and
running again after I
finish this episode.
Let's jump real quick
to the web.
So usually this is the face that
I see on new developers
in terms of speaking on some
specific, new ways to leverage
and utilize HTML5.
When we speaking about modern
web app, what we want to see
is the power of HTML5, the new
APIs, new capability that is
harnessing front-end
developers.
Read what the user are expecting
to get so basically
the native or the desktop
experience, which is mainly
smoothness, responsiveness, and
all the good features of
being close to all of the rich
APIs that we have on each and
every platform.
When we're combining the two,
basically, we're getting
modern web apps.
Here are some bold examples for
great modern web apps--
The "New York Times" reader,
Gmail offline, Angry Bird,
chrome.angrybirds.com, and
Hipmunk, which is a travel
search engine.
All of them are sharing
some very basic set of
skills, if you like.
And here I'll just note that
all of them are coming with
offline first methodologies.
So they will work nicely even
when you don't have any
connection.
They will do the right things
like Google Doc is doing today
in terms of syncing.
And syncing when you are online
and getting the most
important things for you when
you are offline so you could
be productive on a long flight
or if you are in a submarine,
for instance.
When we see more and more logic
being passed to the
client side we want to work with
MV* Framework so we won't
have the case of a
spaghetti code.
All of these apps are
device aware.
So they're using responsive
design to make the most out of
the real estate that their
certain mobile phone, or
tablet, or desktop, or laptop
computer will give them in
terms of screen size.
And when we're saying 60 frames
per second, and meaning
that we want to achieve 60
frames per second so the
response is there, and
smoothness, and the speed in
terms of performance of the app
will be as fast as we can.
Above 60, we don't
gain anything.
It's just a waste because
the eye can't catch it.
And below?
We do want to achieve the best
for our users, don't we?
Three bold examples to what
we are meaning when we say
client-side frameworks.
Angular.js which is open source
project that started in
Google, looking at HTML5 as
if it was a dynamic markup
language and not for static
sites like HTML
was invented to.
And there are some very nice
bold things in this framework
that I highly encourage you
to check like dependency
injection, unit tests from
the ground up, and
other of good things.
Backbone.js which is by far
that most popular MVC
framework today.
I think it deserves the
popularity because it's the
most simple one and giving you
lots of freedom to do whatever
you like or whatever you need
in your specific case.
And Ember.js, which Yehuda Katz
and Tom Dell are doing
and a great ambition
framework.
If you're thinking about a web
app which your user are
spending the vast majority of
their time with reach set of
features, I highly encourage you
the check Ember, as well.
Addy Osmani did a great working
in his Todo MVC, 4
which you have the link here.
So if afterwards you click on
it you could gain all the
compressions between the leading
MV* Frameworks today.
And here you have a link to the
full tutorial that I did
in terms of leveraging Google
Cloud Endpoint with backbone
in our b-wrap.
Why we need offline?
Well, I guess, the first and
foremost is just because users
will gain better performance
and will like your app or
service better.
All the other good reasons
are also valid here.
How to achieve offline.
We have, luckily, today
lots of different
ways to achieve it.
From AppCache to save the basic
building blocks of our
web app like the HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS and up to
local Storage, indexdb and file
API, which letting us
save data locally on the client
side and work with it
like we will work with files
in any other platform.
Or like having a full blown No
SQL DB on the client side,
which is indexdb.
LocalStorage, by the way, is a
very well adopted and most of
the modern web browser out
there are supporting it.
When you going to store that
on the client side, I
encourage you to check libraries
like CloudShare,
which basically giving you the
ability to use modernizer,
check what the specific client
supports, and then use the
best tool for the job.
How we detecting if we're
offline or online.
With simple one liner
navigator.online or window
will know when to do are syncing
and when just to work
in an offline mode.
Some of the cool API that I'll
run over them real quick.
So CSS.
2012 was the flourishing
year for CSS specs.
And one of the main things that
we learned to appreciate
is that the vast the majority
of our users are coming with
different devices, different
scale sizes.
And we want the ability to have
the holy grail of our app
in terms of the main focus of
the center point of the
article, or the main focus
on the app itself.
And then a nice side bar or
footer header and with all the
abilities of CSS like fixed
position or floats or tables
it didn't work.
Luckily for us we have a few new
ways to achieve it and I
would encourage you to
check those two--
the new Flexbox layout and
the grid layout manager.
Basically, we're
achieving this.
That's what I tried to describe,
but a picture worth
a thousand words.
Here it's very true.
And here, there's a link for a
page that eg., my colleague,
did, which basically giving you
the ability to test the
Flexbox, create what you want,
and then just copy paste that
CSS that will do it.
Here you could see nicely that
all the poly fields are being
achieved by the plus sign.
And simple things, like do even
space between elements,
or making sure that they have
the same space around, or
started at the top or the bottom
are just one line here.
Sleek things like stretching
your elements and just making
sure they will be in the same
place are being achieved very,
very easily.
And you know here that when
you writing code--
basically you're reading your
code much more often than
you're writing it so
shorter is better.
And this is just a nice thing to
show you how this short CSS
code is very maintainable.
One other thing is that you
could play when your phone,
let's say, is horizontal and
then it's suddenly vertical--
very, very easily you
could just switch it
with this one liner.
You could also control
the order.
And if here we want the B after
the C, all we need to do
is just say to the Flexbox that
the second child, the B,
which is here will be
in order of one.
And you could see they
change their order.
We could do other nice things
like controlling the B here
and making sure it will be three
times the size of the
other components.
And again, just try and think
and imagine how much more
lines it will cost you if you
want to do it in CSS without
that Flexbox.
It's great here because
basically we're communicating
to the browser exactly what we
want to achieve from it.
And it will do the right thing
even if we are now on a
different screen size,
a different device.
Who is supporting it.
So, luckily, for us it's Chrome,
1 Safari, and IE 10.
And to the ones that doesn't
know Opera just announced two
weeks ago that are moving
to WebKits.
So it's great news because
hopefully soon we'll see it
there, as well.
Dynamic CSS is another fun, very
productive way to create
or basically calculate on the
fly what you want the element
to look like.
And in this case, you can see
that I'm calculating the width
and height and basically giving
it the 100% minus the
element so it work on
different devices.
And basically when I'm hovering
it's just border rad
is zero so you're getting
this nice effect.
And it's supported on all major
browsers as you can see.
And Opera will join the
party soon, hopefully.
Data Binding.
So Data Binding is another cool
way that let's you be
more productive and saves state
and data in the dump.
And in this example I just
wanted to show you how easy
and trivial it is to do
it with Angular.js.
Even if you've never saw
Angular.js code, you could
probably understand that here we
are defining a new Angular
app when we are adding this
meta tag the our div.
And here we're just defining
that our model, basically the
component that will hold
our data, will
be part of the input.
And then we're just rendering it
here with this handle box.
And you could see that I
achieved this nice event of
binding the slider to the value
on the side with this
four lines of code.
Basically, it's three.
Of course, you don't need any
JavaScript framework in order
to achieve it.
We have from the jQuery days the
data attributes that allow
us to actually to have fun and
put one way data binding.
Here it's the poor man's
one, but it's very
productive and it's nice.
Don't get poor in their
wrong context here.
Here you could see that what we
achieved we're just using
the slider element after and
basically calculating the
content of this elements.
And basically after we are
touching this event listener
the data again between the input
slider and the value
that we'll put on this side
will be the same.
One way data binding that's
basically supported on all
major browser is
the data list.
So you could see this really
nice simple markup that
letting us have auto-complete.
And we could do like that.
Or we could start typing and it
will auto-complete for us.
And the good news here is that
it's very useful and supported
on all browsers.
So go ahead and please use it.
Multi-thread programming is
basically something that's
very dear to my heart.
I basically got so excited about
it that in 2011 I wrote
a book about it, "Web Workers."
And you are most
welcome to check it out.
And if not, all of the demos of
the book are on my GitHub.
So feel free to download them
and play with them.
It's a very nice simple API that
lets you construct a new
worker, which basically would
contain a new JavaScript code
that you want to run.
But not on the main thread that
will block the client
painting and do some ugly things
to your user or to your
product responsiveness.
After we declaring or using
the constructor of a new
worker, we're just attaching
to it a new Event listener.
So we'll use postMessage in
order to communicate to the
worker and from the worker.
And in this example, we
just passing it for
the start a few settings.
In the worker, itself, we'll
need, again, to add a listener
so we'll have the
channel open.
And then not all the window.API
are available in
the worker, of course, for
security reasons, but you do
have some nice ways to import
scripts from other places in
[INAUDIBLE], get some offloads,
get some call backs,
and handle the work and
communicate them
back to your parent.
Mainly the page that
created you.
You do want to use Modernizr.
Modernizr, which Paul Irish and
some other great cool guys
are maintaining, lets you have
feature detection and not some
other ugly browser sniffing
out things like that.
And with one line of
Modernizr.webworkers you'll
know if you could leverage the
browser capability or not.
Another very nice aspect that I
wish to see more developers
leveraging is Shared Workers.
With Shared Workers, basically,
you have a worker
which will be shared between
all the tabs or
windows of your app.
So think about Gmail, where
you're opening it in a few
windows or tabs and you want one
source of true that will
communicate to the server
or will act with your
local No SQL DB.
As I mentioned before, all the
examples are on my Github.
So please feel free to check
them out and give me feedback.
One of the things that I
assuming held back leveraging
web workers and seeing then more
and more is it was pretty
hard to debug them.
But, luckily to us, I think it's
from Chrome 18-- and now
we are way on-- currently on
27 soon, you have this nice
check box, which basically if
you and check it you'll get
DevTools to the worker itself.
And you could play with each,
run with it, and inspect, and
do all the other things that
you're doing in order to debug
your worker.
Filesystem.
So like any other platform, yes,
we do have Filesystem.
And you could work with binary
files and text files,
everything is kosher.
And how you are basically
requesting the file system to
allocate your storage,
this is the syntax.
You have three things that you
need to pay attention here,
but because we don't have
too much time I
won't dive into it.
There's a great article on HTML5
Rocks that Eric Bidelman
wrote, which basically will
dive into all the nits and
grits of Filesystem API.
Of course, for security reasons
it will be buying
device and not just floating
there on your hard disk under
whatever you think they are.
But they basically located under
the installation of your
browser and there are Send-box
to the origin, meaning the
protocol, the domain,
and the port.
And you could think about lots
of great things that you could
do with files.
Just like native apps got the
ability to access files on any
other platform, we see more
and more being used and
leveraged in dynamically cashed
assets for games.
For instance, Angry Birds are
using it and they have north
to 100 megabytes of assets.
Basically, one of the great
things about this new API is
that you don't need to
learn anything new.
They're still using the source
of the href in this
example of the image.
And you could get
the toURL here.
And basically get this resource
address, which is
like you would think of a URL on
the web but locally on your
Filesystem.
And with this you just
resolved it.
What's even better is
that all the code is
being handed to us.
And you have this nice library
filer.js on GitHub that lets
you work with files like you
work with files on Unix--
on Linux.
So just check it out.
Very easy.
Your .init the filer with the
amount of memory that you want
to consume on the disk,
the amount of storage.
And then you could do things
like ls or cp and
just work with them.
Here is the example of working
with binary, et cetera.
Yeah, so one of the
things, but OK but
it's only on Chrome.
Well with this shim it
will work on IE 10
and Firefox, as well.
Efficiency data transfer.
Well, one of the main things
were for complex sites like
File, Blob, Array type using
post message wasn't too
productive because it's
not very efficient.
We doing a copy command.
And if you think about, I don't
know, 50 Megs of objects
it won't be too efficient.
And we do have a better way
to do it today with
transferable objects.
Basically, we just copying a
pointer and not everything is
being copied.
So its more of a just a move
operation, and with this test
that we'll have in the next
slide you could see that they
improved their results
50 times.
All we need to do is just have
this second argument here.
And in this case just
try and run it.
As you can see here, I'm running
it inside Chrome.
So I'm getting a response of
three milliseconds, five
milliseconds.
When I try to run the same test
on other browsers you see
measurements of to 150
milliseconds, 300
milliseconds, this
sort of things.
How to do the feature
detection.
Well, with this simple code,
you'll know exactly if the
browser is supported
transferable objects or not.
And right now, it's supported
only on Chrome.
Native hardware.
So, we have a flourishing
ability of HTML5 to expose to
us API's native hardware or
basically bringing us closer
to the metal.
The source of true is
of course on W3C.
And we have some really nice
things today in terms of Geo
APIs, device orientation, WebGL
on the GPU, Filesystem
we spoke, network
connectivity, Battery, Gamepad.
Basically, both USB
and Bluetooth are
encapsulated here.
And WebRTC, which basically
giving you the ability to
attach the video and audio
inputs of the browser.
There's a really cool demo
that Sam Dutton did which
basically show you how Chrome
is speaking with Firefox
through using WebRTC.
Please Google it and enjoy it.
Here is one of the cool
things that I want
to show you on DevTools.
If we go, mark it, and
click on inspect,
DevTools will be open.
Oh, nice.
Let's open it again.
Let's make it to
a bit smaller.
And what I want to share with
you here is, basically, the
ability to go to the Web Tools
and override the user agent
and see how our slides will look
like on the Android Nexus
S. So, immediately
you could see--
let me make it even bigger--
that once I am clicking on the
user agent, I having for free
the device metrics that
are changing for me.
So, I can test it on
different devices.
Let's take, for example,
I don't know, iPhone 5.
So I can see it immediately.
Maybe BlackBerry PlayBook.
Again, so I have all the devices
I have the user agent
and I could do nice things
like over ride the Geo
Location, or the device
orientation, or even emulate
touch event.
So if I want to make sure that,
in this case slides,
will run nicely on your tablet
or mobile device I could call
it a touch event-- and, by the
way, it's working nicely on
mobile devices so please feel
free to consume these slides
from any mobile device.
If you're done with your tests,
you could just click it
and it will return
to the old state.
So, let's make it even be
so it will be easier.
So we saw how you could
mimic some of
the things in DevTools.
It's not replacing your
simulator, but it's definitely
something that you could use
while you are developing.
The first step for speech
enabled apps are
already here in WebKit.
So just feel free to
try and use it.
Let's give it a try.
New York.
And, yeah, you saw that's one of
the things that I know how
to say correctly.
So we have 100% of
success here.
As we spoke about WebRTC, it's
all done through getUserMedia
API and here you could see how
easy it is to just get the
stream from your video
or web-cam.
Here are some really impressive
demos that are just
showing you the tip
of the iceberg.
Please feel free to play
with some of them.
How you recording content.
Basically, with this one liner
we attaching to our object
recorder, the local media
stream, and then later on we
could just use XHR2 in order to
send the information to be
processed or be shared
on the web.
It's supported on Chrome,
Firefox, and Opera.
Hopefully soon on
other browsers.
When we speaking about this
we can't ignore streaming
multimedia these days.
And, luckily for us, web sockets
are now enjoying the
same benefits that web
workers are enjoying.
Basically vice versa on the
first bullet point here.
And you could use a binary
data on them.
And this short example just
showing you how you slicing
Blob and sending it to WebSocket
service to being
manipulated over there.
Chrome Frame.
For the ones that got the a user
base that is still using
IE, maybe IE6, 7, 8,
even 9, we have now
Chrome Frame which--
now, for the past few years--
which basically allows your
users to enjoy all the great
benefits that we saw in HTML5,
drag and drop, WebGL, Geo
information, offline
capabilities, Local Storage,
indexedDB, and more and
more, inside IE.
Now, if you don't have any
control on your server just
add this one meta tag
to your HTML.
And if you have control of your
server, you just need to
send this one HTTP header.
I highly encourage you to check
it out because your
users will thank you.
They could still be, and work,
with the IE, but they will
gain huge improvement in
performance not only on your
app, but on any other app for
popular service like Maps,
Gmail, Docs, that is
supporting it.
Web audio is another very
exciting new API in HTML5.
We don't have time to get into
it, but here are some really
bold examples that just blew my
mind when I looked at them
the first time.
Please feel free to
check them out.
And, as we saw, the web can do
amazing things these days.
And the nice thing about it is
it's just the beginning.
So the base is getting faster
and we're seeing that HTML5 is
basically flourishing
everywhere.
So the web is basically what you
will make out of it and I
can't wait to see new demos that
will showcase and seeing
this iO this year.
Some resources from the talk,
which, basically, one of the
most interesting one is here.
Cloud Endpoint is out of the
Trusted Tester period and if
you want test the water just
feel free to click here and
give it a ride.
Thank you very much.
And if we have any questions
this is a
great time to ask them.
So we had one question in the
chat, but I can't understand.
Do you want to ask it or--
OK.
So, thank you very much
for being with us.
Next week we're going to have
Eze Vidra from Campus London.
And we are going to speak with
Eze on some new cool Start-ups
that are focusing
on making better
consumption by sharing it.
So this is just that teaser.
If you want to dive deeper and
see what are the new trends
that we see both here in Israel
and up there in cold
London, just be with us next
Wednesday at 2:00 PM.
Bye and thank you very much.